Vamos a dibujar o graficar,
algunas desigualdades, así que digamos que tengo la desigualdad "y" menor o igual que "4x" más 3
y lo que queremos es pintar esto en el plano "x", "y"
queremos mostrar todos los puntos "x", "y"  que satisfacen la condición de aquí arriba
así que una forma buena de empezar esto es...
¿qué pasa cuando no es una desigualdad, sino es una igualdad?
es decir... o decir...
bueno déjame ponerlo de esta forma
esto es lo mismo que poner "y" menor que "4x" más 3
ó "y" igual a 4"x" más 3
ajá.. esto es lo que menor o igual significa,
que puede ser menor
o que también puede ser igual y la razón de porqué hice primero este ejemplo es porque
quiero que veamos qué pasa con
esta gráfica que subraye,
entonces pongo mis...
sí, déjenme pintarlo un poquito mejor
eso no... y no, me falló...
ok ahí está, mi eje vertical, el eje "y"
y vamos a pintar el eje "x" justo aquí,
muy bien
ok, y ahora sabemos que esto es una gráfica de una línea, donde se intersecta con el eje "y" en el 3
ok, por aquí pasa, y tenemos la pendiente
que es 4 positivo ¿verdad?
si es 4 positivo, quiere decir que por cada 1
que nos movamos en la dirección de "x",
nos movemos 4 en la dirección de "y"
entonces aquí va a estar otro punto,
ok, ya con esto es suficiente para dibujar una línea ¿verdad?
porque ahora si nos vamos, 1 a la izquierda,
entonces bajamos 4, en la dirección vertical,
así que esto va a ser mi mejor intento de dibujar una línea, espero que realmente salga
esta es la parte más difícil de todo, ok,
se vería algo como esto
esto es una línea debería ser derechita,
pero creo que tienen la idea
y esta es la gráfica de "y" igual a "4x" más 3
así que pensemos en lo que significa
que sea menor éste
así que todos estos puntos, satisfacen la
desigualdad pero tenemos más,
este justo de aquí, por ejemplo, qué pasa cuando...
bueno vamos a... ahí en algunos casos particulares...
vamos a pensar,
¿qué es lo que significa esto?
Así que tomamos algún valor "x" digamos
¿que pasa si "x" es igual a 0?
¿qué nos dice?
entonces si "x" es igual a 0 nos dice que "y" es menor que 4 por 0 que 0 más 3 que es 3
son... digamos ahora cuando "x" es igual a -1,
entonces tenemos "y" menor que 4 por -1 que es -4
más 3 tenemos que es "y" menor que -1
si "x" es igual a 1 digamos "y" sería menor que 4 por 1 que es 4 más 3 es 7
así que tendríamos que "y" es menor que 7
así que vamos a tratar de graficar esto
cuando... cuando "x" es igual a...
déjenme graficar este primero
cuando "x" es igual a 0, "y" es menor que 3,
¿ok? entonces cuando "x" es igual a 0,
tenemos todos estos puntos de aquí,
toda esta línea que estoy sombreando de verde,
satisfacen esto de aquí, si fuera mirar ahora en "x" igual a -1 "y" es menor que -1
¿ok? "y" es menor que -1, así que "y" tiene que ser todos estos puntos de abajo, toda esta línea
cuando "x" es igual a 1, "y" es menor que 7,
ok, entonces si es menor que 7 son todos estos puntos que estoy sombreando
y en general si tomamos cualquier punto, digamos cualquier punto "x",
digamos que tomamos un punto "x" por aquí,
si evaluamos "4x" más 3,
vamos a tener este punto sobre la línea,
que eso es 4 por "x" más 3,
¿ok? y ahora las "y" que satisfacen la desigualdad
pueden ser los puntos en la línea o
todos los que están debajo de ella
así que si hacemos esto,
para todos los posibles "x" que tenemos en la recta...
no, no vamos a tener solo los que están en la línea, que ya hemos dibujado vamos a tener todos los puntos
debajo de esta línea,
así que ya hemos graficado esta desigualdad.
Esencialmente es esta línea con toda el área debajo de ella que estamos sombreando
ahora, si esto fuera un menor estricto
y no un menor o igual
un signo de menor o igual,
entonces no hubiéramos incluido la línea
y la convención que vamos a tomar para
hacer eso, es puntear la línea
así que si esa fuera la situación que estuviéramos tratando con un signo de menor estricto,
ajá, menor estricto que "4x" más 3
en esta situación no aplicaríamos... eh...
poner la línea en el conjunto solución así que,
sólo nos quedaría el área debajo de ella.
Vamos a hacer otro, ahora digamos
que tenemos la desigualdad,
"y" mayor que  "-x" entre 2 menos 6
así que una forma buena de empezar,
y como a mí me gusta hacerlo al menos
es graficar la ecuación de aquí, la línea que tenemos....
aha... asi que vamos a graficar "y" igual a
-1/2 de "x" -6
ok, así que si fuéramos a graficarlo
digamos este es mi eje vertical,
ok, el eje "y",
éste es el eje horizontal, el eje "x",
y nos dice que la intersección con el eje "y" es -6
ok, aquí está el -6,
y mi pendiente es -1/2, aquí debería haber una "x" ¿verdad? es -1/2 de "x"
ok, entonces tengo una pendiente de  -1/2
que quiere decir que cuando voy 1 a la derecha...
perdón, 2 a la derecha, bajo 1 en "y",
si, ok entonces 2 a la derecha y bajo 1
si voy 2 a la izquierda
tengo -2 en "x" y subo 1 ¿verdad?
así que mi línea se va a ver algo así,
más o menos se ve algo así,
es mi mejor intento para dibujar una línea,
así que esta es la línea
"y" igual a -1/2 de "x" menos 6
ahora, nuestra desigualdad no es mayor o igual...
simplemente son todos aquellos números mayores que  -1/2 de "x"
entre 2... ¡perdón!  -1/2 de "x"  menos 6
así que usando la misma lógica que antes, para cualquier "x" que nos tomemos, digamos,
aquí está una "x" particular, si evaluamos en "-x" entre 2 menos 6, tenemos este punto de aquí,
este punto en la línea, pero las "y" que satisfacen esta desigualdad son todas las "y" mayores que eso
así que, no vamos a incluir este punto, de hecho, vamos a poner un círculo abierto,
porque no podemos incluir ese punto
y de ahí, eh...
vamos a tomarnos todas las "y" más grandes que eso
ok, y eso sería cierto para cualquier "x",
por ejemplo, tomamos estas evaluamos  -1/2 de "x" menos 6
obtenemos este otro punto,
ponemos un circulito abierto
y tomamos todas las "y" que están arriba de él
así que todas las "y" que satisfacen esta ecuación
o esta desigualdad son aquellos puntos...
cuyas coordenadas estén por arriba de esta línea
y no estamos incluyendo la línea,
así que como la convención que dijimos,
vamos a puntear la línea,
ok ,déjenme convertirlo en una línea punteada
borrando algunas secciones de esta línea
y espero que al menos para ustedes se vea punteada
así que estamos convirtiendo
esto en una línea punteada
esta es la frontera,
pero no lo estamos incluyendo,
ok, las coordenadas que satisfacen esta desigualdad son, toda esta área sombreada con amarillo
que tenemos por encima de la línea.
Bueno espero les haya sido útil.